jamel debbouze tu vois qui s'est tu vois
pas ouais si jamel debbouze
jamais jamais sudoku internet je
comprend un petit peu ses
applaudissements et cet accueil par ce
que j'ai lu cette semaine dans le figaro
entreprises que vous étiez l'acteur le
mieux payé de france devant gérard
depardieu je les lui aussi j'étais très
déçu par ce qui a été
ce qui a été marqué parce que c'est
complètement faux j'ai touché le triple
ça va venir
que ce soit mais ce qui m'a amusé le
plus c'est la manière dont ça a été
présenté son journal de france 2 parce
qu'il disait à la grande surprise
générale les blues band apart non oui
oui c'est un fait
j'ai trouvé ça j'ai trouvé ça amusant ça
nous fait plus de deux millions d'euros
c'est beaucoup
bonjour tu avais combien de jours de
tournage
six mois de tournage le mans mais en
même temps j'avais aucun problème quand
je touchais 3700 francs contre emploi
solidarité et j'ai aucun problème à
toucher autant tout va bien autant
d'argent aujourd'hui voici du rmb lisf
sans problème je le répète je suis
persuadé mais jamel en plus ça part vite
l'argent et j'en ai plus j'en ai plus là
parce que mon frère mon mot ma cousine
d'audincourt mon frère de gaza et ma
voisine du square le genre a fini bien
plus bien celle du temps reste combien
sur les 2 millions la belle dame restait
700 euros aller simple pour tout ça va
vite et pour les impôts terriens non non
ça ne sais pas quand je me charge avec
une arme et moi je les perds est sûre si
cette pige djamel alors vous venez de
cannes là où vous êtes une star absolue
d'ailleurs j'ai vu dans paris match que
vous étiez avec les plus grandes stars
du festival qui apprécie beaucoup votre
pas vrai j'étais à des amis de la weed
j'étais avec gta dexia la gt avec al abd
el kader aoun
j'étais avec qu'il y avait d'autres on
et j'étais cadet que des cailleras du
7-8
c'est un vieux débat s'est ouverte alors
un parc à loups passé beaucoup de temps
au maroc beaucoup de temps à marrakech
vous avez une maison jamel et où vous
avez monté des studios de cinéma
ouais ouais on est dans les a pas encore
cela fait monter puisqu'on n'a pas
encore on n'est pas encore arrivé dans
la phase où étudiants sont en
construction mais on y arrive on y
arrive très vite et j'espère une charles
1 que dc dc prochain festival du cinéma
à marrakech on puisse poser la première
pierre
ah ouais ouais j'ai été super surpris en
tournant astérix de voir que je n'avais
pas d'à priori mais je ne m'attendais
pas à ce que les marocains connaissent
aussi bien le cinéma j'étais vraiment
surpris et de voir un premier assistant
parlait quatre langues différentes
j'irai 4000 personnes je me suis dit
mais j'ai vraiment vu ça mais qui parle
français anglais arabe dans la même
phrase
mais mais mais mais samassa massama je
me suis aperçu je le savais déjà mois
mais le maroc s'est pas calme c'est pas
coûter à 5 un paysage c'est aussi des
gens tu vois ce que dirait qu'elles
connaissent bien leur caf
donc ça me paraissait évident et logique
de montée des studios c'est une façon en
plus de faire du business et d'aider les
gens qui vivent là bas c'est vraiment
pas pour faire du business parce qu'un
studio finalement ça rapporte pas tant
d'argent que ça d'abord beaucoup au
départ mais moi ma démarche première
c'est vraiment d'essayer d'amener de
faire en sorte que les gens de mon pays
puisse travailler dans les conditions et
les mieux possible les plaies plus
normal puisque on remonte d'abord à
vraiment et les studios à centre
national de l'audiovisuel
ah ouais pour former les gens aux
premiers métiers du cinéma et il a des
marshals purement professionnel d'un
moins avant d'être financière c'est bien
j'essaye jamel debbouze et maroc